les réactions du côté de washington ils
disent vouloir attendre du pouvoir juger
les nouveaux ministres afghans sur leurs
actes les précisions de thomas bonnin à
new york
washington dit vouloir apporter une
réponse commune avec ses alliés
occidentaux à l'égard du nouveau
gouvernement formé par les talibans
raison pour laquelle une réunion s'est
déroulée en visioconférence ce mercredi
autour d' anthony blinken et de son
homologue allemand heiko maas 22 pays y
ont participé ainsi que des
représentants de l'otan et de l'union
européenne le chef de la diplomatie
allemande qui s'est d'ailleurs dit en
faveur lui aussi d'une approche commune
de la part des alliés occidentaux à
l'égard des talibans reste que la
composition de cette nouvelle équipe
gouvernementale ou du moins des noms qui
ont d'ores et déjà été annoncées
risquent de déplaire aux états unis
parce qu'il y a quasi exclusivement des
talibans parmi les noms qui ont été
annoncées qu'il n'ya pas en apparence en
tout cas de volonté de faire preuve
d'inclusivité comme cela avait été
explicitement demandée par les autorités
américaines voici donc ce que anthony
blinken dit de la formation de ce
nouveau gouvernement
bien sûr et hier les talibans ont nommé
un nouveau gouvernement intérimaire nous
évaluons à nice mais bien qu'ils
prétendent qu'un nouveau gouvernement
serait inclusif la liste de noms
annoncés se compose exclusivement
d'individus membres des talibans
ou de leurs proches collaborateurs et
aucune femme nous sommes également
préoccupés par les affiliations et les
antécédents de certaines de ces
personnes nous comprenons que les
talibans ont présenté cela comme un
cabinet intérimaire nous les jugerons
ainsi que sur ses actions la communauté
internationale a clairement indiqué
qu'elle s'attendait à ce que les afghans
mérite un gouvernement plus
la maison blanche qui a indiqué que rien
ne pressait pour la reconnaissance
officielle de la part des autorités
américaines de ce nouveau gouvernement
par intérim
la priorité à l'heure actuelle pour les
etats unis c'est de mener à bien les
différentes opérations d'évacuation de
civils qui sont toujours en afghanistan
c'est d'ailleurs tout sauf un hasard si
anthony blinken a décidé de se rendre à
la fois au qatar et en allemagne qui
sont deux pays qui ont été d centre de
transit très important ces derniers
jours pour les personnes qui ont été
évacuées d'afghanistan et la question de
ces opérations d'évacuation et bien
c'est le sujet majeur pour la diplomatie
américaine en ce moment parce que c'est
aussi le sujet qui cristallise le plus
de critiques n'ayant quasiment plus
aucune ressource humaine sur place le
département d'état américain indique
qu'il est très difficile pour lui de
procéder aux contrôles de sécurité
nécessaires qui permettraient de faire
décoller les avions encore sur place ils
doivent s'en remettre au bon vouloir des
talibans qui contrôlent l ces zones est
d'ailleurs anthony blinken a indiqué ce
mercredi que des taliban avaient empêché
le décollage d'un avion alors cette
situation est le cristallise à un grand
nombre de critiques notamment de la part
d'élus républicains qui reproche au
gouvernement de john dryden une forme
d'inaction voire même de passivité pour
mener à bien justement ces opérations
d'évacuation rappelle qu'il ya encore un
certain nombre de civils qui doivent
être évacués et parmi eux il y a aussi
des américains